Hello. I am Nina.
Dating, dating, dating. Oh my god. It's so boring!  --Call you
You want to hear about all the embarrassing stories, like that time
I had spinach in my teeth or my tampon fell out mid kiss? --Okay, um... What's wrong?
Carrie? Listen, I'm moving to LA. Can you book me shows there or what?
You must be Nina.
This place is beautiful. --I need trees around me. I'm water-based, so I need the balance.
I'm whiskey based. That's more my thing.
Hi, I'm Rafe.
I'm not gonna sleep with you. --Just take it one step at a time!
Okay
I'm no longer married. I was, she broke my heart. --You keep being honest. What's the matter with you?
Hey, Nina. Comedy Prime.
They're gonna give one lucky lady their own one-hour special. Three impersonations, got it? --Nina. This is Celine Dion.
It's just Cher talking to you right now. I'll believe in you. --The next one is Jabba the slut
I met somebody. --Didn't you say you're gonna make me dinner? --Did I say say make you dinner. I meant order.
He's funny, sexy and just the right amount of screwed up
Hey, what up Nina? --What are you doing here? -Wait, don't leave, don't leave. No, no way. Hey--!
No, so this is what you want? You want men fighting over you now?
Nina. The truth will set you free
What if the truth sends you to jail?
People seem to think I'm negative. --Oh! Watch it, bitch. --Not the type of girl you'd want to bring home
It's a brand new world now. --What's the real you?
All in all I think I'm a reasonably good person. Who's with me? Who's with me?!
Thank you. Good night